[Music]
this isn't funny amber when you like to
play a game tara
[Laughter]
doors unlocked
all doors locked
doors unlocked
hello
it's happening
three attacks so far do you have a gun
i'm sydney prescott of course i have a
gun
something about this one just feels
different
samantha i'm i know who you are i've
been through this
a lot
this is your life now which means that
whoever this is is going to keep coming
for you
[Music]
you ready
for this
never
stop
there's certain rules to surviving
the attacks were all on people related
to the original killers
whatever his link is to our past
it's pulled us all back here
and i won't sleep until he's in the
ground
hello it's an honor
i'll be home in the morning where are
you going i'm staying over at susie's
tonight
what's new
the flyer
the papers call him the grabber i wish
you wouldn't comment you don't actually
believe that story do you because he
can't hear you and he doesn't really
take kids that says
you see that
would you hand me my hat
yes sir
i
am a part-time magician
are those type of ones in there
would you like to see a magic trick
i have an announcement to make one of
our students finney blake was abducted
what if i could help the police find
benny
[Applause]
[Music]
does it work
not since i was a kid
i'll scream i'll scratch your face
this face
daddy i had a dream about it what
happened in your dream he was taken by a
man with black balloons yes we never
release those details
huh
don't hang up
who are you
you know all our names
you're getting out of here
please please let the dreams be real see
the wall in front of you i tore a long
cable loose from down there
there's a combination lock on the inside
of the storm door what's the combination
i carved it in the wall
the tree the door the gate i've never
seen it before except in my dreams
you don't have much time
you're gonna use a weapon you raise the
phone step back and swing
look what you made me do
please hurry you remember what i told
you
there's someday i should stand up for
myself someday it's today fan
you look perfect
fly
did you bleed on the carrots well i died
yep probably
[Music]
happy christmas just did alive yes i
think so
jesus they're early tony and simon
robbed the petrol station oh what fun
we make tremendous criminals that felt
so good
we're all getting old we were getting
old
it's just one potato each just one for
everyone
did anyone watch the queen's speech well
she's clearly in some bunkers set up you
know filled with tins of baked beans and
dog food
[Music]
here's to the lives that we've shared
to our beautiful children
our beautiful friend
may we rest in peace
[Applause]
i just think we should be honest with
the kids we know the russians want us
all dead they're sending poisonous gas
to kill us all in the morning it's not
the russians it's the planet it's very
upset
it will kill anything and anyone that is
still alive
[Music]
we should have all voted green
[Music]
[Applause]
we just want to make sure that you
understand that as your parents
we are not to blame
clearly it's not your fault either
[Music]
i've seen the road and there is no whale
living like that
every story has a beginning
discover the origin of evil
why are you back here clear your
conspiracies weren't true when we were
kids they're not true now
we need to expose umbrella
watch this i'm afraid claire i'm afraid
of what they're gonna do to this town
see an umbrella they have an incident
i'm talking chernobyl if you know what i
mean
people are getting sick
you gotta help us claire let the world
know what's really going on
25 years
[Music]
split up
[Music]
being awesome
[Music]
we gotta get out of here
[Music]
we're gonna take umbrella down
[Applause]
hey what are you guys doing out here
it's halloween we've been
trick-or-treating are you alone there's
a creepy man in a white mask
where
and he keeps like trying to play hide
and seek with us where did you see him
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
we killed michael
my grandmother set the fire
[Music]
40 years ago the boogeyman came for us
we are the survivors of michael myers
what do we do we fight
mom or family we'll kill him we're gonna
hunt him down and we're gonna put an end
to this
he is not gonna stop killing until we
stop him
if you track michael's victims that's a
straight line
to michael's child's at home
someone's in our house
he's coming for me
but i'm coming for him
[Music]
i want to take his mask off and see the
life of leave his eyes
[Music]
you're saying what brings you down there
i'm studying london college of fashion
room is on the top floor it's perfect i
love it
i could live any place in any time i'd
live here in
london in the 60s
last night
i saw something in my dreams
[Music]
there was a girl
and you are sandy
[Music]
i got this kind of gear
i can see people's faces
things are this card
this is the closest most people ever get
to their dreams
[Music]
[Music]
what did you see
do you believe in ghosts
[Applause]
you witnessed the murder last night but
you believe this was a vision from the
past
the guy that killed her still like that
i have to stop him
what is storytelling
storytelling started with our indigenous
people
can anyone give me an example of a myth
or a story
they're afraid of
lucas
what's going on
we found a part of a man in the woods
today
part of the man
i guess the other half was found in the
mine
oh this has got to be an animal right
[Music]
no animal that i've ever seen
something is going on with lucas
these drawings belong to a student of
mine
this is what was in the mind
[Music]
into a diabolical spirit
excuse me this is a myth
for you yeah
when knocking again
he is my responsibility
he's here
[Music]
do you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease i'm here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it now
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly
i have increased strength and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of him
he wants to hunt
and consume blood
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
the other half wants to control you hey
uh dr michael you and i should stay in
touch
i'd do anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
all right whenever you're ready
we are shooting a documentary because i
am about to meet my first biological
relative
she's amish i'm not i am not honest
we are humbled and grateful to have our
sister margot return to us
i've always hoped that i could meet you
all so this is a really special moment
for me
hey
mind if i film you for a moment
[Music]
hey
[Music]
i like your doll
what's her name
yeah
you know that was my mom's name
she used to live here a long time ago
she's still here
what did you say
[Music]
whoa
why would they build a church all the
way back here
what is that the demon asmodeus was
trapped inside a chosen woman of god
this has happened before
what the hell
are these from my mom
you can't have me and my baby
i know every i was family within a
50-mile area
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh my god are you sure about this
i have to know
[Music]
[Music]
we've been gifted this beautiful house
we live here
can you believe it
[Music]
they've wanted to keep the place in your
family jamie
we really appreciate the house
well then you
know got a hole in the roof the wheels
they'll do a good job
jamie
you just carry on with your day as if we
weren't here
there is one thing i need to show you
and it's a little bit peculiar
every evening before sunset she'd leave
a blood offering here sorry did you say
blood
for who
for the red caps
[Music]
they'll need feeding
they'll be hungry
can i get in my own house please you
want a deer how many times have the
english come to this country and told us
what's heirs is now theirs
they need to know their place
what did you leave out tonight oh shoot
you can't miss a single day
hello
is anyone there
i can't be scared not in my own house
don't leave your wrists alone with the
lads
[Music]
we just came here for some peace
[Music]
that'll happen
a bomb
i think
[Music]
i don't know why he came all the way up
here
there's nothing left
there are people out there
[Music]
people had finally given up hope
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this package just came in
[Music]
get everybody out here
play me
hello detective banks
do you know where your officers are
jigsaw
i thought that jigsaw killer was dead
he is
find them their hours not days how can i
catch this guy if there's nobody on the
bus i can fuss you can't do this alone
whoever did this has another motive
something personal
was the last time you saw your father
[Music]
that was just a diversion to get us out
of the precinct
i need everyone on this case
he could be anywhere
he could be anyone
we're gonna tear this city apart
[Applause]
[Music]
hello detective banks
when was the last time
you saw your father
you were lucky to get out of those
escape rooms alive i need to know that
the criminals who killed the four people
in front of me are held accountable
hiding in plain sight in the middle of
manhattan we need to stop them i'm in
i know this is a lot to ask but thank
you for coming with me
do you hear that
hey what the hell is going on
you're going to be kidding me
hold on
welcome to mino's escape rooms no no no
what's happening again you guys have
played the game before
so what is this
like a tournament of champions
[Applause]
look we all know how this works we
solved the puzzles or we died
ah i'm advertising most people this ad
yourself is missing an e so maybe we
pull the corresponding handles with a
missing letter
yes
come on we don't have time
[Music]
this is way bigger than last time
i gotta try something right
there's a special reason each of us
survived
i can't feel physical pain just imagine
the kinds of puzzles they came up with
for me
take a picture it will last longer
this looks just like the lighthouse on
the postcard
[Music]
what makes you think they're gonna let
you walk away free again
[Music]
not ever
we need it
we made it
i don't understand we're still in the
game
[Music]
i'm a long way from home
[Music]
this is way tell me gonna help me get my
sister back
i've seen the bodies
they're terrorists the killers ain't
that way you do
we need you
who's your sister
oh fantastic
you reckon you can get us in there
easy
i gotta make this right
so i'm gonna go into that
bunker and we're going to kill every
last one of those sons of [ __ ]
[ __ ] i
oh what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
oh yes
that's one hell of a lovely skull good
work rhys you dumb son of a [ __ ]
come on
[Music]
what the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] me
[Music]
[Music]
apparently it's very difficult to access
at the bottom of this part of the lake
there's a perfectly preserved house
let's go
there she is
[Music]
i
[Music]
what is that
i get to go to town today right
you need to pass all your tests
failed the gun is in my hand
remember the guy is blind but he's still
dangerous
find a girl
[Music]
let's hunt this [ __ ]
[Music]
it's not me you need to be scared of
little girl
the man standing next to you
i don't know who he is
but i know who he's known
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
now
you're gonna see what i see
[Music]
there was a cracked man
[Music]
this is where it all began
the story of candy man
look after he walk around handing out
candy to the neighborhood kids
one day
a couple of kids get razor blades in
their candy
police come around
that's when i saw the true face of fear
get on your knees hands hands
they beat him
towards him
a couple weeks later more razor blades
and more candy
he'd been innocent so he's real candy
man ain't he
candy man's the whole damn hive
if you're out here looking for candy man
you ask me
stay away
i feel really connected to this story
god
right here in this neighborhood
the legend started uh-huh
and the legend is
if we say his name five times while
looking in the mirror we could summon
him summon the candy
[Music]
black people don't need to be summoning
no
i dare you don't say that say he's like
you better not do that last one
you want to be a part of the story right
no
say his name
candyman
[Music]
anthony
anthony
anthony
are you okay
the hell is going on
this neighborhood is haunted
i think i made a mistake
i brought him back candyman isn't real
he told me
he has purpose for you
new to the neighborhood
you should say candyman say his name
[Music]
is
[Music]
this is lidvark
there is something very very wrong here
we have to go now
it won't let you live
this is litvak what won't let me leave
the magic
it will make you see terrible things
[Music]
will find another broken person
she's here
listen i have a story for you something
the examiner will love
a healing
possibly divine
a girl performing miracles after a
visitation from the virgin mary
chicago new york see every demographic
on this planet is eating this up
give me the exclusive
all right i think i got this all set up
what do you say we do a couple real easy
questions how many are gonna watch mary
wants to reach as many people as
possible
maybe millions
[Music]
there are people out there that don't
believe in your miracles
how would you respond to those folks
seeing is believing
and why do you think mary chose you
i opened myself up and welcomed her in
witnesses of the virgin mary draw
millions of faithful each year
the vatican's been tasked to investigate
this visitation from the blessed virgin
i have read several libraries worth on
the supernatural
investigated half of those miracles
prove him all false
[Applause]
[Music]
she's here
you think there could be other forces at
play here
well god builds a church the devil
builds a chapel
next door
don't doubt her
doubt weakens faith
[Music]
hail mary full of grace
pray for us sinners now and at the hour
of our death
this is not the work of the virgin mary
it's the work of the unholy
faith in evil
and poverty
believe in her
offer
your souls
to mary
holy mary mother of god
the lord is with you
happy anniversary pumpkin things have
been bad between us and i'm sorry
i don't know when surprise isn't gonna
fix everything
i love you with all of my heart
until death do us part
i'm impressed you made it this far
there's one final surprise
happy anniversary pumpkin
we're not leaving until we open that
safe
200 grand in rocks we split the diamonds
let's go
two people knew the combination to that
state
the guy who hired us
and the girl
she could be miles away by now
she's still in the house
[Music]
such a perfect couple
i'm gonna cut myself free of you if it's
the last thing i do
you know what we wouldn't have found who
would have stayed on the trail
what is that
the story people here know but don't
talk about except in whispers
anyone who goes up there
what is this place
they don't come back
descendants of these people are still
living up there on the mountain
[Music]
i saw something out there
[Music]
someone
[Music]
the largest organism on the planet looks
right here
growing
waiting
and it's ready
to spread
be
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how is this possible
do you know what this place is
your mother angela she's our patient
i've been out of touch with her for a
very long time
thank god her mind is very active in the
simulation simulation
she went on a homicidal rampage
this is your chance to ask her why
mom
carly you have to go
you have to go
guys
please let me out
are you sure that you haven't been
having any hallucinations outside of the
simulation
[Music]
[Applause]
demonic possession it could be real
i can't do this
you won't end up like your mother
the vatican has been funding a black ops
unit
he's increased like soldiers
now that it's free
it won't stop coming for you
[Music]
stop right there
no kids allowed on the beach
oh no
we never leave each other nothing
separates us
are we there yet you said five minutes
technically it's been more than five
minutes let's just all start slowing
down
[Music]
wow you believe i found this online i
guess it's not that secret of beast
who would leave this from the hotel
they're so rusted what's happening found
stuff from the hotel in the sun
[Music]
what happened to her mom i don't know
what happened to her body has decomposed
how quickly can that happen seven years
but she just died wait where are the
kids
cara come here hey have you seen my
children mom
i'm i'm right here
dad why are you looking at me like that
[Applause]
what's happening to us
my daughter just turned six two weeks
ago
whatever's happening to us is happening
very fast you have wrinkles
there's something wrong with this speech
what's
people are blacking out going this way
she makes it to the ledge she might have
a chance oh she's stopping what's she
stopping can i wake up wake up
[Music]
they have to know what this place does i
don't know you're a liar look what is
that a message
we never leave each other nothing
separates us we're connected to
something bigger
oh no
we're here for a reason
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to willie's wonderland
spend the night cleaning willie's
wonderland i will pay to have your car
fixed
deal
you are officially on staff let's get
the hell out of here i can't stand to
hear a grown man scream
this place has a dark history
i know the [ __ ] story they told you
it's a lie
you're here to be a human sacrifice
have you been listening to a word i've
been saying
he's gonna die in here but he won't
listen to
you
me
[Music]
[Music]
we're going to willy's
he's not trapped in here with them
we are trapped in here with him
it's birthday time i enjoy a man a few
words
when i was young
something happened to me
i'm just not saying that daddy
who are you talking to
gabriel
is he your imaginary friend whatever you
went through before you joined our
family it hurts you in a way that i
can't even imagine
you created him daddy
what's going on
so that you could survive
i wanted to do something that was a bit
different but yet huck back to my roots
you got to take chances if you don't you
end up making the same old thing again
and again and again
i think audience is our star for
something that's new and different
[Applause]
we are going to turn back the hands of
time close your eyes
he's
who is gabriel
i'm the only one that can see him
that's him
he wants to talk to you
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
malignant
radar september 10th
[Music]
you